This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. A couple of years ago, we presented a story produced by Paragren Andrews about how certain sounds, like the sounds of skis on a cross-country track, or hoofbeats on a horse racing track, were faked on sports broadcasts. It ended up being one of our most popular and provocative episodes ever, meaning because people really taken it back by the notion that any part of a sporting event might be faked. That episode was just a small excerpt of a much longer documentary called The Sound of Sport. And we got a number of requests from our audience over the years asking where they could hear the entire piece. And today, my friends, we are going to present it to you in its full glory. This is a fascinating, exquisitely produced, deep, deep dive into the sound design of
这里是99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。几年前，我们播出了由帕里格林·安德鲁斯制作的一期节目，讲述了某些声音（比如越野滑雪赛道上的滑雪板声，或是赛马场上的马蹄声）是如何在体育转播中被伪造的。这最终成了我们最受欢迎且最引发讨论的单集之一，因为人们对体育赛事的任何部分可能是伪造的这一概念感到十分震惊。那集节目只是一部更长的纪录片《体育之声》中的一小段。这些年来，我们收到了听众的大量请求，询问他们在哪里可以听到整部作品。今天，我的朋友们，我们将向你们完整地呈献它。这是一个迷人、精美制作、深度剖析……
sports broadcasting. A subject that I've met most people have never even considered before. That's just one of the reasons why I love it. Keep in mind, this was a rivently broadcast in 2011, so it's after the World Cup in South Africa and before the London Olympic Games in 2012, so just to place you in the proper sports history context. This is The Sound of Sport, produced by Peregrine Andrews for voluntary productions and presented by Dennis Baxter.
体育转播音响设计的专题。这是一个我发现大多数人以前甚至从未考虑过的主题。这也是我热爱它的原因之一。请记住，这最初是在2011年播出的，所以它在南非世界杯之后、2012年伦敦奥运会之前，正好让你处于正确的体育历史背景中。这是《体育之声》，由佩雷格里纳·安德鲁斯为志愿者制作公司制作，丹尼斯·巴克特主持。
I like listening to sports. I can close my eyes. I can hear every single one in my head. It's my belief that people have ingrained in them a memory of certain sounds, and if that sound is not fulfilled, then the mind knows that there's something wrong. There is an expectation of what football sounds like, and it certainly wasn't. The vizellas, the plastic of the World Cup in South Africa and those damn Vuvuzillas. For many people, this was the first time they'd really thought about how sports to sound. But it's what I spend my life thinking and dreaming about. I'm Dennis Baxter, and I design the sound of sports for television. For nearly 20 years,
我喜欢听体育比赛。我闭上眼睛，就能在脑海中听到每一个声音。我相信人们内心深处都对某些声音有着固有的记忆，如果这种声音没有被满足，那么大脑就会知道出了问题。人们对足球听起来应该是什么样有着一种预期，而它绝对不是那样的。呜呜祖拉，南非世界杯上的塑料喇叭，还有那些该死的呜呜祖拉。对许多人来说，这是他们第一次真正思考体育听起来应该是什么样。但这是我一生都在思考和梦想的事情。我是丹尼斯·巴克特，我为电视设计体育节目的声音。近20年来，
I've worked exclusively on the Olympics as their staff sound designer and engineer. I decide how to capture each event sonically so that it brings as much drama and excitement into the home as possible. They get away at first time, Paul has got a very good start, so did Dexel. I'm gearing up for London 2012. It is going to be a big job. I'll be using a team of 350 sound mixers, about 600 sound technicians and close to 4,000 microphones.
我一直专门从事奥运会的工作，担任他们的专职音响设计师和工程师。我决定如何从声学上捕捉每个赛事，以便将尽可能多的戏剧性和兴奋感带入千家万户。他们起步很好，保罗开局非常不错，德克塞尔也是。我正在为2012年伦敦奥运会做准备。这将是一项巨大的工作。我将使用一个由350名调音师、大约600名音响技术人员和近4000支麦克风组成的团队。
It's a new, long record! I was born in Atlanta, Georgia, 1954, and essentially I think that I've been a sound person my entire life. When I was about eight or nine years old, my dad bought me a cassette recorder, and I was recording everything. I would go into the bathroom, my mom would be on the toilet, and I would just pop in with the microphone and start recording her. Monkle had a restaurant, and I washed an awful lot of dishes, and when I was 14 years old,
这是一个新的长纪录！我于1954年出生在佐治亚州亚特兰大，基本上我认为我一辈子都是个与声音有关的人。当我大约八九岁的时候，我爸爸给我买了一个磁带录音机，我当时在录制一切。我会走进浴室，我妈妈正在上厕所，我就会拿着麦克风突然闯进去开始录音。蒙克开了一家餐馆，我洗了大量的盘子，当我14岁的时候，
had enough money to buy a real real recorder. It was around $1,000 at the time. It was a staggering sum in 1968. This is the size of a big suitcase. I couldn't drive, so I used to hitchhike and carry that record to the churches and to the high schools and record just about anything that I could possibly record. I was a veteran so I went to school on my GI Bill and studied economics. They taught me a lot about borrowing money.
有了足够的钱买一台真正的录音机。当时大约是1000美元。在1968年，这是一笔惊人的巨款。这有一个大行李箱那么大。我还不会开车，所以我过去常常搭便车，把那个录音机带到教堂和高中，几乎录下我能录制的一切。我是一名退伍军人，所以我靠《退伍军人权利法案》上学并学习经济学。他们教给我很多关于借钱的知识。
So at the end of my college degree, I had done my final papers on a recording studio and had convinced a bank to loan me the money and before I knew it, I was several hundred thousand dollars in debt. That recording studio dream is a misguided dream that you're going to make your own music and live happily ever after. And then all of a sudden you're struggling to get people into the studio recording things that you don't want to record and frustrated with the situation. Music
所以在大学毕业时，我以录音室为题写了最终论文，并说服了一家银行把钱借给我，不知不觉中，我就背负了几十万美元的债务。录音室的梦想是一个误导的梦想，你以为你会创作自己的音乐并从此幸福快乐地生活。然后突然之间，你却在挣扎着让人们来到录音室录制你不想录制的东西，并对这种现状感到沮丧。音乐
We're just minutes away from the first event on the ESPN schedule. In 1982, I found another and more profitable use of audio skills at the newly formed sports television channel ESPN schedule. In 1982 I found another and more profitable use of audio skills at the newly formed sports television channel ESPN. Instead of musicians now I was capturing the sound of car racing, tennis, baseball, football, whatever they sent my way. Your Majesty I humbly ask you to declare the Olympic Games of 1948 open. That was the first Olympics to be televised by the BBC, though fewer than 100,000 homes
我们距离ESPN赛程上的第一场比赛只有几分钟了。在1982年，我在新成立的体育电视频道ESPN上找到了我的音频技能的另一个更有利可图的用途。在1982年，我在新成立的体育电视频道ESPN上找到了我的音频技能的另一个更有利可图的用途。现在，我不再是捕捉音乐家，而是捕捉赛车、网球、棒球、足球以及他们送给我的任何比赛的声音。陛下，我谦卑地请您宣布1948年奥运会开幕。那是第一届由BBC电视转播的奥运会，尽管当时拥有电视的家庭不到10万户。
had television at the time. As you can hear, there is just past Nankivo. And it's Erickson's contour to the finish. Erickson is sweet and one strand. Like how you say it's a whole strand. As you can hear, there isn't much more than commentary to be heard. Six was Bergkiss, six Bergkiss and seventh Nankivo. My own relationship with the Olympics began in 1992 when I was offered the first full-time job as a soundseater.
正如你所听到的，刚刚过了南基沃。埃里森正朝着终点线冲刺。埃里森状态很好……就像你说的那样，这是一条完整的赛道。正如你所听到的，除了评论之外，没有听到太多别的声音。第六名是伯格基斯，六号伯格基斯，第七名南基沃。我与奥运会的关系始于1992年，当时我获得了第一份全职音响主管的工作。
I went back and listened to every single sport, trying to understand why we were covering the sports the way that we were, what sounds were there, and what sounds were really missing and why. I came from music, I came from a recording studio, and I wanted to apply those techniques and standards to the live world. And one of the first things we implemented in the Olympics was a lot more close-miking. This is where you put a microphone as close as possible to the sound source. If you use this technique, you need a lot of microphone because each microphone can only capture a little piece of the whole picture. But you get more detail
我回去听了每一项运动，试图了解我们为什么要以这种方式报道体育运动，那里有什么声音，什么声音真正缺失了以及为什么。我出身于音乐界，我来自录音室，我想将这些技术和标准应用到现场世界中。我们在奥运会上实施的第一批事情之一就是增加近距离拾音。这就是把麦克风尽可能靠近声源的地方。如果你使用这种技术，你需要大量的麦克风，因为每个麦克风只能捕捉到全貌的一小部分。但你会得到更多的细节
and definition and a hell of a lot better sound. and a elbow and a better sound. The parallel bars and the uneven bars for the women's gymnastics. When you put the microphones that close to the athlete, you hear the flexing of the bar. You hear the breathing. You can even hear the rustling of the clothing. My dad was very anti-rock and roll and he goes, okay, I'll get you a guitar and I was just thrilled. Well, come Christmas morning, he got me a guitar and it was an acoustic guitar with a Chad
和清晰度，以及好得多的声音。还有高低杠和女子竞技体操的高低杠。当你把麦克风放得离运动员那么近时，你会听到杠的弯曲声。你会听到呼吸声。你甚至可以听到衣服的沙沙声。我爸爸非常反对摇滚乐，他说，好吧，我给你买把吉他，我当时兴奋极了。嗯，圣诞节那天早晨，他给我买了一把吉他，那是一把带有查德
Ackon's record. And I love Chad Ackon to this day, but for the next two years after I got the acoustic guitar, all I was trying to do was make it louder. And I stumbled across the contact microphone, which is a device, a microphone that you actually can stick right onto the top of the guitar to amplify. It picks up the actual vibrations of the wood and consequently the sound of the guitar. 30 years later, I'm looking at gymnastics. The balance beam is a synthetic resin type of material that athletes, they balance on, they do somersaults, they do all kinds of routines on top of it. And I'm hearing this balanced being, I say, I mean, that has a certain resonance in there
阿肯唱片的木吉他。直到今天我都非常喜欢查德·阿肯，但在我得到木吉他后的头两年里，我所做的全部事情就是想把它弄得声音更大。我偶然发现了接触式麦克风，这是一种设备，一种你实际上可以直接贴在吉他顶部来放大的麦克风。它能拾取木材的实际振动，从而拾取吉他的声音。30年后，我正在看体操。平衡木是一种合成树脂材料，运动员在上面平衡，做空翻，在上面做各种各样的动作。我听到这个平衡木的声音，我说，我的意思是，里面有一种共振
that we cannot hear, that someone probably has never heard. Is that a new texture that we should put into the mix? And by the time we put the contact microphones on there, it gave a new level of depth because the contact microphone hears the vibration in the entire bar. Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaaaa, Niharaaaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaaaaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaaaaa What? Be it for fun! For sets, Roger Federer to serve. Ready? Ready. 2008.
我们听不到，别人可能也从未听过。这是不是我们应该加入混音中的一种新纹理？当我们把接触式麦克风放上去时，它提供了一个新的深度级别，因为接触式麦克风听到了整个杠的振动。尼哈拉，尼哈拉，尼哈拉，尼哈拉……什么？为了好玩！各就各位，罗杰·费德勒发球。准备好了吗？准备好了。2008年。
Here we go. Play. In 2008, the team responsible for the sound of the Wimbledon-Mins file was nominated for a BAFTA award. I love atmosphere. That is my job as far as I'm concerned. It's the atmosphere that you generate that makes people be there. that makes people be there. I'm Bill Wiston and I'm the sound supervisor who did the sound for the 2008 Wimbledon tennis finals, the Gents. That's the sound of Wimbledon. That hush, the bouncing of the ball on the court.
我们开始吧。开始。2008年，负责温网男子决赛声音的团队获得了英国电影学院奖（BAFTA）提名。我喜欢氛围。就我而言，这就是我的工作。你营造的氛围能让人身临其境。
That atmosphere is the sort of thing that I am trying to bring into the home. That hush, when everybody is fully expectant of something brilliant to happen. There's lots of microphones on the court. Basically the court is covered by a very nice small stereo mic. Stuck on the back of the court just above the centre-line judges' head. So that occasionally causes an interesting moment when they shout. Hi! I'm not that excited with the call of the right place line, but what was the call of the front? Mae'r ymwch i'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy And you will no doubt have seen on close-ups of the chair when the contestants are sitting either side of the chair during changeovers that you have an array of microphones actually
这种氛围正是我试图带入千家万户的东西。那种每个人都满怀期待会有精彩事情发生的安静。球场上有许多麦克风。基本上球场被一个非常好的小型立体声麦克风覆盖。贴在球场后方，正上方靠近司线员头部的上方。所以这偶尔会引起一个有趣的时刻，当他们大喊时。嗨！我对正确位置线判罚的呼喊不是很兴奋，但对前面的呼喊是什么？……毫无疑问，当你在特写中看到裁判椅时，当参赛者在换边时坐在椅子两侧时，你会发现其实有一排麦克风
on the chair. And those are used to these days ever since Mr McEnroe's outburst to try and pick up anything that's interesting and said to the Ompaer. Crawford serves, lines get to back in the centre, Crawford drives into the net, that's bad, man for him. The way tennis used to be covered way back in the early days was to actually have what was called an apple and biscuit microphone. They'd stick that over the top of the umpire's chair so you've got a bit of umpire on as well as the rather distant smashes of the ball. His service puts him at such an advantage even when Crawford gets it back, if he's able to come up and value it and put the more where he likes.
在椅子上。自从麦肯罗先生爆发以来，这些天这些麦克风被用来试图捕捉对裁判所说的任何有趣的话。克劳福德发球，球回到底线和中路，克劳福德抽球入网，对他来说这可真糟糕。早期网球报道的方式实际上是拥有所谓的苹果和饼干麦克风。他们把它夹在裁判椅的顶部上方，这样你既能听到一点裁判的声音，也能听到相当遥远的击球声。他的发球让他占据了如此大的优势，甚至当克劳福德把球回过来时，如果他能够上网截击并将球放在他喜欢的地方。
Crawford returns the service and it's out. Any love? When I first joined outside broadcasts, they were still doing mono. It was early 80s and I was asked to do court two in stereo to see if we could develop a technique for doing that. I came to in the end using quite a posh and expensive and not very weatherproof microphone which is a beautiful stereo microphone but really normally used for covering orchestras and then that meant that your players were actually moving around, left to right, as they
克劳福德回球，出界了。零比零？当我刚加入室外转播时，他们还在做单声道。那是80年代初，我被要求用立体声做二号场，看看我们是否能开发出一套技术来做到这一点。我最后使用了一个相当昂贵、高级且不太防风雨的麦克风，这是一个美丽的立体声麦克风，但通常用于录制管弦乐队，这意味着你的球员实际上是在左右移动，当他们
ran around the court. 15 ohm. That's now evolved into a surround technique where you have not only the crowd and the players in front of you, but the crowd also goes all the way around the back of you. So when you're in the middle of a cheering crowd, when it's been accorded well, the surround really involves you in the play, if you like. It's like actually being there. 3015. The dynamic range, the difference between the quietest noise and the loudest noise doesn't have to keep you on your toes.
在球场上奔跑时。15比0。这现在已经演变成了一种环绕声技术，你不只有你面前的观众和球员，观众甚至一直延伸到你的身后。所以当你处于欢呼的人群中间时，如果录制得当，环绕声真的会让你沉浸在比赛中，如果你愿意的话。就像身临其境一样。30比15。动态范围，也就是最轻的声音和最响的声音之间的差异，并不需要让你时刻保持警惕。
If you've got the court mix on a fader and you take that fader down in anticipation of it getting very loud on the court and you do it ahead of time, you ruin the effect. What you've got to do is time it in such a way that the second that that quiet atmosphere changes into the huge roar from the crowd, you've got a split second to fade down that effect, if you like. APPLAUSE Over the years, I've managed to develop this sort of sixth sense in a way that I can guess pretty much now, nine times out of ten, what the crowd's going to do. Getting that exciting stillness, anticipation,
如果你把球场混音放在推子上，并且为了预判球场上声音会变得非常响而提前把推子拉下来，如果你提前做了，你就毁了这个效果。你必须掌握好时机，在那个安静的氛围变成观众巨大咆哮声的瞬间，如果你愿意的话，你只有一个微秒的时间把这个效果推小。掌声多年来，我设法培养了这种第六感，在某种程度上，现在十有八九我基本上可以猜到观众会做什么。获得那种激动人心的静止、期待，
and then this huge roar when it's all developed into something really wonderful. And of course, keeping the commentator on top of it. Well, that would be the right time to serve your first ace. And I'll now, with a second set point. What was brilliant about that particular final was that they let it breathe. They didn't talk all over it all the time. I have had a number of people say to me,
然后在一切发展成非常美妙的事情时发出巨大的咆哮。当然，还要让解说员保持在这一切之上。嗯，那将是发出你的第一个Aces球的好时机。我现在的第二个盘点。那场决赛的精彩之处在于他们让它有了呼吸感。他们并没有一直在上面喋喋不休。我曾听不少人对我说过，
is there any way that we could have a feed without a commentator? I think that would be something that people would really appreciate. You could add your own commentary then. But juicers of the old school would tell a commentator to shut up. I don't think many do now. I'm Barry Davis and for a few years I've been a commentator on various things. When a goal is scored, I would just call my commentator for his position just for five wind up the sound of the crowd and then let him come in. I used to try and make a thought in my mind that if you can't think of what to say, say nothing, which is actually the best policy, but invariably one forgets that from time to time, we don't carry it away with the emotion. Euro 96 when England played Germany in the semi-final. I can remember very well.
有没有办法让我们获得没有解说员的直播信号？我认为这会是人们真正欣赏的事情。那样你就可以添加你自己的解说。但老派的导演会叫解说员闭嘴。我想现在没多少人这么做了。我是巴里·戴维斯，几年间我一直是各种赛事的解说员。当进球得分时，我只会为我的解说员调整好他的位置，留出五秒钟放大观众的声音，然后让他切进来。我过去常常在脑海中告诫自己，如果你想不出该说什麽，那就什麽也别说，这其实是最好的策略，但往往人们有时会忘记这一点，被情绪冲昏了头脑。96年欧洲杯英格兰在半决赛对阵德国。我记得非常清楚。
Four, I would have thought something close to ten minutes before the teams came out. So much good sound from around the stadium. Just with a few observations and commentators. Everyone joining in. The famous... those who come to support the opposition. And those only well known to their friends. People may be unaware of what I'm trying to achieve, but if you've got a bunch of people sitting at home going,
在四强赛，我想在球队出场前差不多十分钟左右。球场周围有那么多美妙的声音。只需做一些观察和解说。每个人都加入进来。著名的……那些来支持对手的人。而那些只为他们的朋友所熟知的人。人们可能没有意识到我在努力实现什么，但如果你有一群人坐在家里说，
gosh, wasn't that a terrific match. They don't actually say gosh wasn't the sound terrific but you know that is so much part of it. In a football match what we do nowadays is to have a stereo atmosphere mic and then 12 mics around the pitch, which you fade up and down as the ball moves up and down the pitch, in other words chasing the ball around, so you can get the kicks and the scuffles and the shouting and all that sort of stuff. It's a difficult technique to get across to people who haven't done it before. It's anticipating where the ball is going to go. Personally, I don't favor the system of fixed microphones around the pitch that Bill describes.
天哪，那场比赛真棒。他们其实并没有说天哪声音真棒，但你知道那是其中很大一部分。在一场足球比赛中，我们现在所做的是拥有一个立体声音场麦克风，然后在球场周围放置12个麦克风，随着球在球场上下移动，你可以调大和调小它们的声音，换句话说就是追着球跑，这样你就能听到踢球声、争抢声、喊叫声以及诸如此类的各种声音。对于没有做过的人来说，这是一项很难掌握的技术。那就是预测球会去哪里。就我个人而言，我不赞成比尔所描述的在球场周围放置固定麦克风的系统。
I prefer to use four roving operators who each point a directional microphone at the action. They follow the action. I believe that this gives a better, more defined kick sound and a some method I've used at the last four Olympics and we're using London for the 2012 football events. What you're hearing now is a game from the Athens Olympics in 2004. The In every Olympic games, I try to rush of the excitement and entertainment value. And certainly, winter sports are fun because you're trying to convey a sense of speed and motion.
我更喜欢使用四个游动操作员，每个人都把一个定向麦克风指向动作发生的地方。他们跟随动作。我相信这能提供更好、更清晰的击球声音，这也是我在过去四届奥运会上使用的方法，我们将在伦敦2012年足球比赛中使用它。你现在听到的是2004年雅典奥运会的一场比赛。在每一届奥运会中，我都试图冲刺兴奋感和娱乐价值。当然，冬季运动很有趣，因为你试图传达速度和运动感。
I've always enjoyed the sound of Bob's sled. In Vancouver, there were 44 cameras. At each camera position, there was a distinctly different oral perspective and I was trying to put the viewer, the listener, into place of the athlete. And I made every camera position a sound zone. Some people may say that 284 microphones is a bit excessive. But you have to remember that every camera perspective, every visual perspective for the viewing audience has a different sound texture and a different sound color. It's like a piece of music that if you just sit and listen to the crowd, you hear like how it swells and dives and peaks and then suddenly bursts, it sounds to me like an orchestra.
我一直很喜欢雪车的声音。在温哥华，有44台摄像机。在每个摄像机位置，都有一个截然不同的声音视角，我试图把观众、听众置于运动员的位置上。我把每一个摄像机位置都变成了一个声音区。有些人可能会说284个麦克风有点过头了。但你必须记住，每一个摄像机视角，为观众提供的每一个视觉视角都有不同的声音质感和不同的声音色彩。它就像一首音乐，如果你只是坐下来听人群的声音，你会听到它如何起伏、跌宕和达到顶峰，然后突然爆发，在我听来它就像一个管弦乐队。
I'm Rob Nox. I'm a sound effects recordist for movies in Hollywood. I get hired by the movie studios to record sounds specifically for their movie. For example, if you have a specific sports movie, be it horse racing, hockey, figure skating, football, basketball, they bring me into capture the essence of the crowds and the game itself.
我是罗伯·诺克斯。我是好莱坞电影的音效录音师。我被电影公司雇佣来专门为他们的电影录制声音。例如，如果你有一部特定的体育电影，无论是赛马、曲棍球、花样滑冰、足球、篮球，他们都会把我请去捕捉观众和比赛本身的精髓。
The sound of the basketballs, the sound of horses hooves, horses breathing, players tackling each other, all that kind of good stuff. So they bring me in so that they can recreate the feeling of being really into that event when you see the movie. The game of their lives, it was the greatest team in any sport I have ever seen. The game of their lives is a football movie, the 1950 US men's national soccer team that was competing in the World Cup in Rio in Brazil and they went on to be England
篮球的声音，马蹄声，马的呼吸声，队员们互相扑抢的声音，诸如此类的好声音。所以他们把我请去，是为了在你看电影时重现那种真正融入比赛的感觉。《Their Finest Hour》是一部关于橄榄球的电影，讲述了1950年参加里约热内卢世界杯的美国国家男子足球队，他们对阵的是英格兰队。
Which was shocking at the time because England was the best team on the planet and America was probably One of the worst teams. I was asked to go down to record football crowds for the movie in North America We don't have football crowds that are that exciting and ran bunches. I went to Brazil and I recorded football games. I went to Marumbi Stadium to record a game between Brazil and Bolivia, and the crowd was insane. I would just move around the stadium and listen for pockets of chanting and cheering or loud fans and listening for the energy. They are out of their mind singing in huge 10 foot drums.
这在当时令人震惊，因为英格兰是地球上最好的球队，而美国可能是最差的球队之一。我被邀请去为这部电影录制足球观众的欢呼声。在北美，我们没有那么让人兴奋且成群结队的足球观众。我去了巴西，录制了足球比赛。我去了马拉卡纳体育场录制巴西队和玻利维亚队的比赛，观众们简直疯狂了。我只是在体育场里四处走动，寻找歌唱、欢呼或大喊大叫的球迷，聆听那种充满活力的声音。他们疯狂地唱着歌，还敲着十英尺高的大鼓。
When you can feel someone screaming and their guts are coming out as they're yelling, that's going to translate when you hear it in the movie. So I'm looking to record the people that are really passionate and into it. And so I would set up near them. I had a handheld recorder. I'd try to not let them know I was recording. So I didn't want to change their performance.
当你能感受到某人在尖叫，声嘶力竭地呐喊时，当你在电影中听到它时，这种感觉就会传递出来。所以我想要录制那些真正充满激情、全身心投入的球迷。我会在他们附近架设设备。我有一个手持录音机。我尽量不让他们知道我在录音，因为我不想改变他们的表现。
Hey! Good work! Hey! Hey! Hey! Hey! Hey! Hey! Hey! Hey! Hey! Hey! If you have people in the loop group, you know, actors, they're not going to go that deep
嘿！干得好！嘿！嘿！嘿！嘿！嘿！嘿！嘿！嘿！嘿！嘿！如果你让配音组的人来，你知道的，演员们，他们不会表现得那么深情，
and scream like a fan and an audience welcome. It's amazing. When you can recreate with real people that energy, that's the way to do a sports movie. That's a feel! Yeah! Sound puts you in the actual environment, and it really does create an emotional response. My name is Gordon Dürerty. I am the studio audio director, Adelaide Tronik-Arts Canada, specifically the sports video game end of the company.
像球迷和观众那样热情欢呼。这太神奇了。当你能用真实的人重现那种活力时，这才是制作体育电影的正确方式。那种感觉！太棒了！声音能把你带入实际的环境中，它确实能引发情感共鸣。我叫戈登·杜尔蒂。我是加拿大艺电公司（EA Canada）的工作室音频总监，专门负责公司的体育电子游戏业务。
So we make games like FIFA, hockey, soccer, American football, golf, pretty much the entire range of sports. We're taking a scientific approach to a very emotional process, which is, let's re-analyze how crowds work. Instead of this big wash of sound where everything's happening at once, because that guy in the corner there whose face is painted purple, and he's got his team shirt on, and he's got a big drum, and he's trying to get his corner of the stadium all riled up.
所以我们制作诸如FIFA、冰球、足球、美式橄榄球、高尔夫等几乎涵盖所有类型的体育游戏。我们正以科学的方法处理一个非常感性的过程，那就是：重新分析观众是如何运作的。不再是那种所有事情同时发生的大杂烩般的声音，因为角落里的那个家伙脸上涂成紫色，穿着球队的球衣，拿着一个大鼓，正试图让体育场他那个角落的人们都兴奋起来。
Maybe a wave starts around the stadium, or maybe it doesn't. So our future push is, let's get into actually modeling all riled up. Maybe a wave starts around the state and maybe it doesn't. So, you know, our future push is, let's get into actually modeling how crowds behave and how these different particles of sound actually interact to create a large crowd. We work a lot at how can we keep improving the actual game experience. We try to bring it down as authentic as possible, but then we have to go beyond because normally you would not hear the details of the sound on the pitch on TV, but as a gameplay you expect to hear the kicks. For this last South African world cup, we hired people in South Africa to record the crowds.
也许人浪会在体育场里传开，也许不会。所以我们未来的推进方向是，真正去模拟观众是如何行为的，以及这些不同的声音粒子是如何相互作用以形成庞大的人群的。我们花了很多时间研究如何不断改进实际的游戏体验。我们尽量使其尽可能逼真，但随后我们必须超越现实，因为通常你在电视上是听不到球场上的声音细节的，但作为玩家，你期望听到击球声。对于上一届南非世界杯，我们在南非雇佣了人员来录制观众的声音。
We have to build a game quite a few months in advance of the event. We actually had the crowds come back from South Africa and I went down to one of the audio sound guys rooms and I kept hearing the speed hives going on. What is this thing? This is driving me bonkers. Can we not turn that thing off or down? You guys know this is this vuvazela thing. It's part of the thing but you have to have this or it's not authentic. So we actually put a mute button on, finally, to say that you can mute it or lower the volume of it. And then when the actual World Cup started in South Africa, people were saying, you know,
我们必须在赛事举办前好几个月把游戏做好。实际上，南非的观众录音送回来后，我去了一位音频音效师的房间，我一直听到嗡嗡的声音在持续。这是什么东西？这快把我逼疯了。我们不能把它关掉或调小吗？你们知道这就是那个呜祖塞拉（vuvazela）喇叭。它是比赛的一部分，但你必须有这个声音，否则就不够真实。所以我们最后确实加了一个静音按钮，说你可以将其静音或降低音量。然后，当南非世界杯真正开幕时，人们纷纷表示：
how come the TV channels can't just put a mute button like they do in the actual video game? Dovina is another one of my favorite sports. This is a great example of really trying to isolate the micro-sounds of the sport. You can really separate the above sounds in the swimming hall and the below sounds, the underwater sounds. Really conveys the sense of focus and the sense of isolation of the athlete. We have microphones on the handrails as the divers walk up. You can hear their hands, you can hear their feet, you can hear them breathing. Eyes, eyes, eyes. I'm five. Oh. We have a microphone at the bottom of the pool under the water.
为什么电视频道不能像实际的电子游戏那样加入一个静音按钮呢？跳水是我喜爱的另一项运动。这是一个很好地尝试隔离这项运动微观声音的例子。你可以真正分离开游泳馆内上方的声音和下方的声音，也就是水下的声音。这真正传达了运动员的专注感和孤独感。当跳水运动员走上来时，我们在扶手上安装了麦克风。你可以听到他们的手声，听到他们的脚声，听到他们的呼吸声。眼睛，眼睛，眼睛。我是五号。哦。我们在泳池底部水下安装了一个麦克风。
The athlete goes under the water, we shift the perspective to just them in the underwater sound. You hear the bubbles. You get the complete sense of isolation, the complete after hearing the coverage in Barcelona of the 92 Olympics. There were things that were missing. The easy things were there. The third in the impact of the target. That's a no-brainer in a little bit of the athlete as they're getting ready. But it probably goes back to the movie Robin Hood.
当运动员潜入水下时，我们将视角切换到他们和水下声音本身。你能听到气泡声。你获得了彻底的孤独感，在听了巴塞罗那92年奥运会的报道后。有些东西缺失了。简单的东西都在那里。击中靶子的声音。在射箭中这显而易见，还有运动员在准备时的呼吸声。但这可能要追溯到电影《罗宾汉》。
I have a memory of the sound, and I have an expectation. So I was going, okay, what would be really, really cool in archery to take it up a notch? And the obvious thing was the sound of the arrow going through the air to the target, which was the type of sound.
我对声音有记忆，也有期待。所以我当时想，好吧，在射箭中加入什么东西会非常非常酷，能让它更上一层楼呢？显而易见的声音就是箭穿过空气射中靶子的声音，就是那种声音。
So we looked at a little thing, called a boundary microphone. They lay flat, it was flatter than a pack of cigarettes, I put a little windshield on it and I put it on the ground between the athlete and the target and it completely opened up the sound to something different. And then I pulled the point, total 0.7-1.
所以我们研究了一个小东西，叫做边界麦克风。它们是平放的，比一包香烟还要薄，我给它装了一个小防风罩，把它放在运动员和靶子之间的地上，它彻底打开了声音的格局，变成了完全不同的东西。然后我拔出了箭，总共0.7-1。
For some reason, directors don't like to see the microphones. They do like hearing good sound, but there is a resistance to actually seeing microphones in the picture, which is one of the challenges that we have. And the boundary microphone fulfilled that challenge because you could creep the microphone closer to the actual source. Because the ampah has to line up the boat's first wall and get them into line and see if they're both straight.
出于某种原因，导演们不喜欢看到麦克风。他们喜欢听到好的声音，但对于在画面中看到麦克风存在抗拒心理，这是我们面临的挑战之一。而边界麦克风完美地解决了这个挑战，因为你可以把麦克风悄悄靠近实际的声源。因为裁判必须排好船的第一道墙，让他们排成一排，看看他们是否都笔直。
The ampah has been down, he came down about a quarter of an hour ago to line up the actual stake bridge. The engine of the launch has started up and the excitement is growing quite visibly or orderly on both sides of the river now. I wonder if you can hear them on this type of a. Well, we find ourselves on a quite glorious day down on the Thames of the boat race and it's absolutely magnificent. Paul Davis, I'm an executive producer with BBC Sport, look after tennis, rugby union, golf, the boat race and a few other things. Sound is, it's a hidden jewel, isn't it, really? I mean, I think it's one of those things that one takes for granted because for obvious reasons you can't see it and when it's going great,
裁判已经下来了，他大约在一刻钟前下来排列实际的木桩桥。快艇的发动机已经启动，河两岸的兴奋情绪正在明显而有序地增长。我想知道你是否能在这个类型的设备上听到它们。好吧，我们在一个非常辉煌的日子来到了泰晤士河观看划船比赛，这里绝对宏伟。保罗·戴维斯，我是BBC体育的执行制片人，负责网球、橄榄球、高尔夫、赛艇和一些其他项目。声音，它是一个隐藏的宝石，不是吗？我的意思是，我认为这是那种被理所当然忽视的事情之一，因为显而易见的原因你看不见它，而当它进展顺利时，
no one sort of refers to it, when it it goes wrong there is literally a deathly silence. I'm a huge supporter of sound in outside broadcast television and I think the guys that we work with really respect that. My name's Andy James, I'm a sound supervisor. We're at the other boat race at Putney and my job is about augmenting what you're seeing with what you hear. Everything we've done has been fine. Okay, I've saved my own pre-delay. Whenever I look at a shot, I want to try and better it with a sound.
没有人会特别提及它，当它出错时，简直是一片死寂。我是户外转播电视中声音的坚定支持者，我认为与我们合作的伙伴们真的很尊重这一点。我叫安迪·詹姆斯，是一名音频主管。我们在帕特尼的另一场赛艇比赛现场，我的工作是将你所看到的与你所听到的结合起来。我们所做的一切都很好。好吧，我保存了我自己的预延迟。每当我看到一个镜头时，我都想尝试用声音来改善它。
That's always my aim. So Paul cuts up a really, really good shot of the crews and you can see the looks on their faces. I want to hear every bit of effort they're putting into that stroke and that's really what our job is about. Make sure that every shot Paul cuts up we can match it with sound and make it even better. I'm looking at the gym at the opposite of the bowed house. There's a nice lower balcony that's very clear and
这一直是我的目标。所以保罗剪辑了一个非常非常棒的船员镜头，你能看到他们脸上的表情。我想听到他们在那个划桨动作中付出的每一分努力，这正是我们工作的意义所在。确保保罗剪辑的每一个镜头，我们都能用声音与之匹配，并让它变得更好。我正看着艇库对面的健身房。那里有一个很棒的低层阳台，视野非常清晰，
would look very good I think. Quite often a lot of the motivation for directing an outside broadcast is visually driven but often I think that can come from sound as well. And if we have two very motivated coxes and they're both mic'd up and they're delivering some outstanding sound then there's a real motivation A to hear that sound, to understand what they're delivering instruction wise and actually just to add atmosphere as well, then that's hugely motivating in terms of going visually to their cameras to see the cocks delivering it and then how the rows are reacting to it as well. So those motivational reasons
我想这看起来会很不错。很多时候，导演户外转播的动力往往是视觉驱动的，但我认为这通常也可以来自声音。如果我们有两个非常积极的舵手，并且他们都戴着麦克风，传递出一些出色的声音，那么这就具有真正的动力：A.听到那个声音，理解他们在指令方面传达的内容，以及实际上只是为了增加氛围，那么在视觉上去切到他们的镜头，看舵手如何传达指令以及划手们如何对此做出反应，这是极具激励作用的。所以这些听觉上的激励原因
for hearing sound I think is great, rather than it just being wallpaper. We're passing the boat houses now, we're just going to take the Oxford Stroke. Now then, in, out, one, out, two, out, three, out. We're sort of bleeding through Georgie, but again, really good. I've got three and four of the coxies, but I don't have one and two. Okay, seven boat house and eight boat house. So Oxford on seven. On the boat race, we've got about six different shore sites
对于听到声音来说我认为太棒了，而不是让它只成为背景墙。我们现在正经过艇库，我们即将拍摄牛津大学划手。好了，进，出，一，出，二，出，三，出。我们有点声音串传到乔治那里了，不过还是很好。我有三号和四号舵手的话筒，但我没有一号和二号的。好的，第七艇库和第八艇库。所以牛津在第七艇库。在赛艇比赛中，我们大约有六个不同的岸上站点
all the way down the course. We're at Putney at the moment, which is where the boats start. And we've got various stereo effects mics up and down the towpath. And then as we move from site to site, moving down the course, we have local effects mics there that are radio link back to us here where I can mix them in to the main
贯穿整个赛程。我们目前在帕特尼，那是比赛开始的地方。我们在纤道上下安装了各种立体声效果麦克风。然后，当我们从一个站点移动到另一个站点，沿着赛程前进时，我们在那里设有本地效果麦克风，通过无线链路连接回我们这里，在这里我可以将它们混入主
sound. We also have mics on the crew boats themselves and on the chase boats, so we can pick out the various different effects that we need as the boats move off down the river. The time has come. We start off the first half of the programme, we'll all be a presentation element when the presenters will be introducing what's going on, Clair Bauding will be with us. And this is the time, their time. Good afternoon, it's just gone according to four, we are live in the boat house of last year's winning crew Cambridge University.
声音中。我们的参赛队员船只本身以及追踪船上也装有麦克风，这样当船只沿河驶离时，我们就可以挑选出所需的各种不同效果音。时机已到。我们开始节目的前半部分，当主持人们介绍正在发生的事情时，都会有一个展示环节，克莱尔·鲍丁（Clair Bauding）将与我们在一起。这就是他们的时刻，属于他们的时刻。下午好，刚刚过四点，我们在去年冠军船队剑桥大学的艇库进行现场直播。
So that's the first element and then we move into the race itself and I'm basically moving along my sound desk from left to right. Starting for... Just give us five minutes, Joe. Hi. I've got a 96-fader mixing desk here and I'm starting from the left hand end. I've got my commentary mic stand when in. The first stroke is so important.
所以这是第一部分，然后我们进入比赛本身，我基本上在我的调音台上从左到右移动。开始... 给我们五分钟，乔。嗨。我这里有一个96推子的调音台，我从最左端开始。我的解说员麦克风架已经准备好了。第一桨非常重要。
It has to be good. 600 more to come but the first one is the platform which is the best. We've got various high-distant effects mics, one up on the hoist, which gives them a panoramic view of Patney. Then we move on down towards I like to backfade the 41 by now,
它必须表现出色。还有600米要划，但第一桨是基础，这是最好的。我们有各种高处的远距离效果麦克风，一个在吊车上，可以俯瞰帕特尼的全景。然后我们继续往下移动，我喜欢现在把41号推子向后混音，
we're into mics in the boat houses themselves. Then we're kind of into the race itself, the start of the race, and we've got the umpires, both as the umpires get the race started. Then there's the Oxford and Cambridge boats themselves, and there's two effects mics that hopefully pick up the sound of the rowing. The coxies on the boats have a mic on them, personal mic on them. Yeah, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice 20 seconds 20 Pass it No! Jenny ready for a 4-10 10 10 10 10
我们进入了艇库本身的麦克风。然后我们有点进入比赛本身，比赛的开始，我们有裁判，当裁判让比赛开始时。然后是牛津大学和剑桥大学的船只本身，有两个效果麦克风有望捕捉到划船的声音。船上的舵手身上有一个麦克风，个人麦克风。好的，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好落后三分之一艇身。
10 10 10 10 10 10 Sometimes the language that comes from the Cox isn't broadcastable so we have to have an alternative to go to and that's part of the on a live job like this you've got to work out what the cox is are saying is it transmittable but nevertheless what they're saying is it gives you really good information I'm not right there boys. I'm not right there. Turn it on the bend boy. Steading third of a length down.
有时舵手说的话是不能播出的，所以我们必须有一个备用方案，这是在像这样的一场直播工作中的一部分，你必须弄清楚舵手在说什么，它是否适合传播？尽管如此，他们所说的话确实为你提供了非常好的信息。我不在那里，伙计们。我不在那里。在弯道处转弯，伙计。稳住，落后三分之一艇身。
Shining on boys. Shining on the bend boy. Steading on the bend boy. Steading third of a length down. Shining on boys. Steading on the bend boy. Steading on the bend boy. Steading third of a length down.
加油，伙计们。在弯道加油，伙计。在弯道稳住，伙计。稳住，落后三分之一艇身。加油，伙计们。在弯道稳住，伙计。在弯道稳住，伙计。稳住，落后三分之一艇身。
Shining on boys. Steading on the bend boy. Steading on the bend boy. Steading third of a length down. Shining on boys. Steading on the bend boy. Steading on the bend boy The boys stay long on the road. Just think about that. The boys for ten. Think about that, boys. Ready? Go! Coming into the pit! Woo!
加油，伙计们。在弯道稳住，伙计。在弯道稳住，伙计。稳住，落后三分之一艇身。加油，伙计们。在弯道稳住，伙计。在弯道稳住，伙计。小伙子们在航道上坚持住。想想看。伙计们坚持十划。想想看，伙计们。准备好了吗？走！进入冲刺！呜！
Then we're into the various shore sites. So there's another 15 fades down there of shore sites which will be able to pick up the crowds that are locally watching from the various different places on the race. They tend to give us a good bit of colour because they're all having parties. It's about building up a multi-layered or rural picture. Ops from there, heading towards Victory. It is all that's starting there. It is Chazic Bridge at the top of your picture and the finish line sits just before that. to the left hand side and Simon went to leave this his work again, shouting not letting
接下来我们就来到了各个岸边观赛点。岸边还有另外15个混音点，可以捕捉到在赛道不同地点现场观看比赛的人群的欢呼声。他们往往能为我们提供很多活力，因为大家都在开派对。这关乎于构建一个多层次、全景式的画面。从那里出发，向维多利亚方向前进。一切都从那里开始。画面上方是查西克桥，终点线就在它的正前方。左侧是西蒙再次准备出发，大声呼喊，毫不
up. They will not let up Oxford. Cambridge run for the winning post. Oxford, two on the two lengths behind, two on half lengths behind. Flags gone down, Cambridge run, one, Cambridge run by two on a half lengths behind, flags gone down, Cambridgeer 1, Cambridgeer 1 by two and a half lengths. Cambridge have won the boat race of 1933. Cambridge still had a slightly higher stroke rate, but into the final straight they come. And the pace, of course, from Oxford has dropped slightly, hunched the girls' time,
退让。牛津大学绝不退让。剑桥大学向终点冲刺。牛津，落后两艇身，落后两艇半身。旗帜落下，剑桥获胜，剑桥领先两艇半获胜，旗帜落下，剑桥获胜，剑桥领先两艇半获胜。剑桥赢得了1933年的赛艇对抗赛。剑桥的划频率依然略高一些，但他们进入了最后的直道。当然，牛津的速度略有下降，女孩们的姿态有些紧绷，
but the jade is on the stun. As a spectator, you actually see very little of the race. You'll see the start, all the finish-ups and we're in between. What we can do is actually convey an atmosphere throughout the whole race for the viewer, so you actually get a much better experience. After the peak last year, in 2011, the Thames belongs to Oxford. To them, the victory, the smiles, the celebrations, the spoils, everything is theirs and Cambridge had for his left. I think it's all about layering. With pictures, there's a degree of layering, but it's fairly clear cut. Literally, you're cutting between pictures.
但奇迹正在上演。作为观众，你其实只能看到比赛的很少一部分。你会看到起跑和终点，以及中间的一些片段。而我们能做的，实际上是在整场比赛中为观众营造一种氛围，让他们获得好得多的体验。在经历了2011年的巅峰之后，泰晤士河属于牛津。对他们而言，胜利、微笑、庆祝、战利品，一切都属于他们，而留给剑桥的只有……我认为这完全在于层次感。在画面方面，存在一定程度的层次感，但界限相当分明。字面上看，你就是在不同的画面之间进行切换。
With the sound, I think you can build up the layers. Covering anthems, for example, during six nations. And whether you, when you go to the anthems shots of the teams, and you're tracking along the close-ups of the players, do you actually want to hear the choral singing of the stadium, or do you want to hear in all your respect the fairly poor singing of the individual players? That's an interesting mix that the sound guys have to deal with, because you want the personality and clearly they know the words but often they're not sung very well. If you didn't hear their sounds at all, then you'd feel a bit cheated. Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, For years we used to sit with a radio mic on the referee but it wasn't transmitted.
而在声音方面，我认为你可以建立不同的层次。例如，在六国橄榄球赛期间播放国歌。当你把镜头切换到各支球队的国歌特写，并沿着球员的特写镜头移动时，你究竟是想听到体育场的合唱，还是出于尊重，听到个别球员其实并不怎么样的歌唱？这是一个音响师必须处理的有趣混音，因为你想要个性，显然他们知道歌词，但通常唱得并不是很好。如果你一点也听不到他们的声音，那你就会觉得有点被忽咒了。噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，多年来，我们习惯于在裁判身上佩戴无线麦克风，但并没有进行广播。
And then eventually the rugby union officials decided to let us transmit this wonderful addition to the commentary. That's what it is. It's part of the commentary. And I think it adds so much. I don't think you could use the technique for football. Take the hits, please on contact. You make sure you go straight. You go straight. technique for football. Touch! Holes! Hey guys! So the addition of a microphone on the rugby referee opened up another dimension. It puts you right into the game. You can be the player. I believe that is the future of sports sound.
后来，橄榄球联盟的官员终于决定让我们转播这个对解说极其精彩的补充。事实也确实如此。它是解说的一部分。我认为它增色太多。我不认为这种技术可以用在足球上。请承受撞击，在接触时。你要确保你走直线。你走直线。足球的技术。界外球！接住！伙计们！因此，在橄榄球裁判身上加装麦克风开辟了另一个维度。它能让你身临其境地融入比赛。你就像是场上的球员。我相信这就是体育声音的未来。
Microphones on the athletes and players themselves. If you can persuade them to wear them. Yep! microphones on the athletes and players themselves, if you can persuade them to wear them. And here's another sport that benefited hugely from this technique. We're trying to catch, we're trying to catch. Curling was introduced to the Olympics in 1988 when the winter Olympics went to Calgary and the rest of the world going curling. We're trying to catch, we're trying to catch. Calgary and the rest of the world going curling, curling. How are we going to make curling exciting? How are we going to introduce curling to the world?
在运动员和选手自己身上安装麦克风。如果你能说服他们佩戴的话。没错！在运动员和选手自己身上安装麦克风，如果你能说服他们佩戴的话。这里还有另一项极大地受益于这项技术的运动。我们在试图接住，我们在试图接住。冰壶运动于1988年冬季奥运会落户卡尔加里时被引入奥运会，随后全世界都开始玩冰壶。我们在试图接住，我们在试图接住。卡尔加里以及全世界都在玩冰壶，冰壶。我们该如何让冰壶变得激动人心？我们该如何向世界介绍冰壶？
And early on we started putting microphones wireless, microphones on the curlers. That's all. Oh yeah, if we know that it's a pretty big pocket, if we freeze in the back we're not, no it's it. They're a strategy, they're encouraging each other, they're Or... They're a strategy.
早期我们开始在冰壶运动员身上佩戴无线麦克风。就是这样。噢，是的，如果我们知道那是一个相当大的口袋，如果我们呆在后面不动，不，就是这样。他们有战略，他们互相鼓励，他们在或者……他们有战略。
They're encouraging each other. They're talking, they're constantly talking. There's a lot of screaming. It's a very, very vocal sport. There's a half-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or- audience and it has really been a huge boost in the ratings and the interest in the sports. With a video game it's an interesting position in that you are the player on the field. You're also the viewer of the game, so you're sort of in this weird place where you're sort of a spectator, but you're also an active participant. What we found with the sound is that we had to pretty much exaggerate. For instance, on a boxing game, we record the real boxes, but we just don't get the clean sound to get like things like grunts and groans and punches and impacts.
他们互相鼓励。他们在交谈，他们一直在交谈。有很多尖叫声。这是一项非常、非常注重声音的运动。还有……观众，这确实极大地提升了收视率和人们对这项运动的兴趣。对于电子游戏来说，它的定位很有趣，你既是场上的球员。你同时也是比赛的观众，所以你处于一种奇怪的境地，你既是观众，也是积极的参与者。我们在声音方面发现的是，我们几乎必须夸张处理。例如，在拳击游戏中，我们录制真实拳手的声音，但我们无法获得像粗重喘息、呻吟、击打和撞击那样干净的声音。
So we go into a studio and sometimes we'll recreate a boxing ring to do the feet and the falls. And then what we'll do is we'll close Mike, it's called a foliardis, it's basically the people that do the footsteps and all the sort of hand props and everything for film and television. We'll have the person punch a punching bag or a side a bee for whatever and just get all of the actual punch sounds. A high, low, medium, hard, different angles. Then we'll get voice down to coming and do things like all the,
所以我们会去录音室，有时会重建一个拳击台来制作脚步声和摔倒声。然后我们要做的就是进行近距离收音，这被称为“拟音艺术”，基本上就是为电影和电视制作脚步声、各种手持道具和一切音效的人。我们会让演员击打沙袋、击打蜂箱或其他什么东西，只为了获取所有真实的击打声。高、低、中、重，不同的角度。然后我们会请配音演员来做各种声音，比如，
the boxing sniffs and all the grunts and groans, and we'll then do things like, break celery and lard into a body impact sound to get like a cracking rib type of sound. So all of those elements we carefully craft in a studio environment, and then when we layer that back into the game and we blend that in and then we add the live crowds from the venues and we dress it all up, the whole net effect of that is that it does feel fairly authentic. On the tennis game called Grand Slam Tennis, what I did, and I stick a lot of tracking down, was try to get tapes from the French Open. It's similar, I got some tapes from Wimbledon as well.
拳击时的吸鼻子声以及各种粗重的喘息和呻吟声，然后我们会做一些诸如将西芹和猪油砸向身体来模拟肋骨断裂的声音。所有这些元素都是我们在录音室环境中精心制作的，然后当我们将这些声音重新分层加入游戏中并进行融合，再添加来自比赛现场的真实人群欢呼声并将它们全部包装起来，最终的整体效果是它确实感觉相当逼真。在网球游戏《大满贯网球》中，我所做的是——我收集了大量的音轨，尝试获取法网的录音。同样地，我也从温网获取了一些录音。
So we were able to get a number of matches with different players and different sizes of venues and just basically extract the crowd from there. And Mac and Ro, the William sisters, grunts, they have very unique sort of streaks and screams that tennis players do. We were actually able to pull that off the tape as well. I think it was Venus said wow, you know, it sounds just like me serving. I said well, it is exactly're serving, because it is you serving that we extracted.
因此，我们能够获得大量包含不同球员和不同场地规模的比赛录音，并基本上从中提取出观众的欢呼声。麦肯罗、威廉姆斯姐妹的击球喘息声，网球运动员发出的那种非常独特的呐喊和尖叫声。我们实际上也能从磁带中提取出来。我想维纳斯曾说过，哇，你知道的，听起来就像我发球一样。我说，嗯，这确实就是你发球的声音，因为我们提取的就是你的发球声。
15. I was doing American car racing. They call it NASCAR. And this particular race was a half mile oval. And essentially, what would be considered a football type stadium with very high banking. The cars put out 140 decibels of sound, maybe more than you put 40 of those cars on a half mile track and it just sounds like a hornet nest. There's no real definition. Then all of a sudden the show is over and there supposedly is the roar of the crowd,
15。我当时在做美国赛车比赛的音效。他们称之为NASCAR。这场特定的比赛是一个半英里的椭圆形赛道。基本上，这可以算是一个带有非常高坡度的美式足球场类型的体育场。赛车会发出140分贝的声音，甚至可能更高，如果你把40辆这样的赛车放在半英里的赛道上，听起来就像是一个马蜂窝。根本没有真正的清晰度。然后突然之间比赛结束了，按理说应该有观众的欢呼声，
but the producers screaming, I can hear the crowd, I can't hear the crowd. It's a very basic physics issue where the sound that I want or being massed or being drowned out by these cars. So I said, okay, you know, I learned my lesson. I went back to my home studio and I started pulling up some crowd samples and building different textures and things like that. So my next race, you know, when they showed the crowd, I started sneaking some stuff in. And when it came to the end of it, it was a very, very nice crowd swell. a very, very nice crowd as well. And the same producers, you know, you get in the out of the boys and you know, this is great. This is what I want. This is what we're trying to achieve. And then a week later he found out that I'd use the sample. And
但制作人尖叫着，我能听到观众的声音，我听不到观众的声音。这是一个非常基础的物理问题，我想要的声音被这些赛车的声音掩盖或淹没了。所以我说，好吧，你知道的，我吸取了教训。我回到家里的录音室，开始调出一些观众的采样，并构建不同的纹理等等。所以在我的下一场比赛中，你知道的，当镜头切到观众时，我开始偷偷加入一些音效。当比赛接近尾声时，这是一个非常、非常美妙的观众欢呼声浪。一个非常、非常美妙的观众欢呼声浪。同样的制作人，你知道的，你从那些小伙子们那里得到了反馈，你知道的，这太棒了。这就是我想要的。这就是我们试图达到的效果。然后一周后他发现我用了采样。然后
then I get a call and said, you're cheating. And I'm saying, well, you know, all right, who am I cheating? Am I cheating the audience? No, the audience sees a crowd. The audience has certain expectations. You'll see a crowd, you hear a crowd. There's some sports that you just cannot capture the natural sound. Cross-country skiing, byathlon is another one because of the size of the course. And this has been further complicated because as the camera lenses have gone up 110, 120, 130,
我接到一个电话，对方说，你在作弊。我说，好吧，你知道的，好吧，我在欺骗谁？我在欺骗观众吗？不，观众看到了人群。观众有一定的期望。你看到人群，你就会听到人群的声音。有些运动你就是无法捕捉到自然的声音。越野滑雪、冬季两项是另一类，因为赛道太长了。这让情况变得更加复杂，因为随着摄像机镜头的变长，110倍、120倍、130倍、
140 to one, these cameras are able to see a half a kilometer or maybe a kilometer down the course. Now how do you replicate that sound? Essentially if if you've got cameras that are that far apart from each other, you're putting 20 or 30 microphones to fill as the athletes are coming to you, which is not practical. I am not a purist whatsoever in sound production. I truly believe that whatever the tool takes to deliver a high-quality, entertaining soundscape is all fair game. And that has caused some issues because I use samplers. What a sampler is, it's a keyboard that's attached to essentially a digital recorder.
140倍，这些摄像机能够看到赛道前方半公里甚至一公里的地方。现在你如何复制这种声音？基本上，如果你有相距这么远的摄像机，你得安装20或30个麦克风来在运动员向你跑来时填补声音空白，这根本不切实际。在声音制作方面，我绝对不是一个纯粹主义者。我坚信，无论采用什么工具来呈现高质量、引人入胜的音景，都是完全可行的。这引发了一些问题，因为我使用了采样器。什么是采样器？它本质上是一个连接到数字录音机的键盘。
When you hit the key on the keyboard, it triggers the sound to play back and with the keyboard it also triggers with sensitivity meaning that if I hit the key real hard it'll have a little bit more of a harder attack and you can vary the pitch. If I hit a step. So for the ski end, it gives a sh. Sh. Sh. Sh. Sh. Sh.
当你按下键盘上的键时，它会触发声音播放，而且通过键盘，它还能根据触感力度触发声音，这意味着如果我用力敲击琴键，它就会有更强烈的起音，并且你可以改变音高。如果我踩出脚步声。所以对于滑雪末端，它会发出沙、沙、沙、沙、沙、沙、沙的声音。
Sh. Sh. Sh. Sh. Sh. Sh. Sh. Sh.
沙、沙、沙、沙、沙、沙、沙的声音。
Sh. Sh. Sh. Sh. Sh. Sh. Sh. Sh. Sh. Sh. Sh. Sh my biggest problems was rowing. Rowing is a two kilometer course. They have four chase boats following the rowers and they have a helicopter.
沙、沙、沙、沙、沙、沙、沙、沙、沙、沙、沙、沙我遇到的最大问题之一是赛艇。赛艇是一项两公里的赛事。他们有四艘跟随赛艇的快艇，还有一架直升机。
That's what they need to deliver the visual coverage of it. But the helicopter and the chase boat just completely wash out the sand. So no matter how good the microphones are, you cannot capture, you cannot reach, and isolate sound like you do visually. But people have expectations, okay? If you see the rovers, they have a sound that they're expecting. So what do we do? That afternoon we went out on a canoe with a couple of rowers and recorded stereo samples of the different type of effects that would be somewhat typical of an event. And then we loaded those recordings into a sampler and played them back to cover the shots of the boats.
那是他们用来提供视觉转播所需要的。但直升机和快艇的声音完全把声音给掩盖了。所以无论麦克风有多好，你都无法像视觉上那样捕捉、触及和隔离声音。但人们是有心理预期的，对吧？如果你看到赛艇运动员，他们会期待听到某种声音。那我们该怎么办？那天下午，我们乘独木舟带着几名赛艇运动员出发了，录制了可能对这类赛事比较典型的各种特效的立体声采样。然后我们将这些录音加载到采样器中，并在播放画面时回放这些声音，以覆盖船只的镜头。
The Australians have bitten something back from them, but not enough. Great Britain, gold medals, Stephen Redgrade, Matthew Benson, mission accomplished. Standby. And they're racing. Good evening to Spatch, although Victoria Spanches dropped back to last early, first to begin on the far side
澳大利亚人从他们那里扳回了一城，但还不够。英国队，金牌！史蒂芬·雷德格雷夫，马修·班森，任务完成。待命。比赛开始了。晚上好，斯帕奇，尽管维多利亚·斯帕奇在早期落到了最后，但率先在远端发力的是……
as Dan Ceeces is out there in the early stages going far two is. When we do our horse racing, you're not going to get somebody running around the course after the horses, because no way. And occasionally you will come across very close up pictures of the horses over the far side, which is done off one of our roving cameras.
当丹·西塞斯在早期阶段冲到前面时，两个是……当我们转播赛马时，你不可能派人在赛道上跟着马奔跑，因为这根本不可能。而且偶尔你会遇到来自远端马匹的极近景画面，这是由我们的移动摄像机拍摄完成的。
But you have engine noise in that case, so therefore you wouldn't want a microphone on that, because all you would hear is the car revving up and the camera and cursing. So basically, the way you cover all that sort of stuff is to run a tape which has the sound of horses who's galloping, which is actually, if I remember rightly, a slowed down buffalo charge. Buffalo charge. And if they're doing hurdles you will have a tape which has the sound of somebody falling through a hedge, I suppose you call it, it's rustling all the time. So as they go through or over, hopefully the hurdle, you actually fade this up and if you're clever at it you vary the level a little bit so it sounds like several horses going through together. That's pretty much a standard thing and I think it's probably the same recording they've used for years.
但在这种情况下会有发动机噪音，因此你不会在上面安装麦克风，因为你听到的只会是汽车的轰鸣声以及摄像师的咒骂声。所以基本上，你涵盖所有这类素材的方法是播放一段录音，里面有马奔跑的声音，如果我没记错的话，这实际上是放慢了的野牛冲锋声。野牛冲锋的声音。如果他们在跨栏，你会播放一段录音，里面有某人掉进树篱的声音，我想你可以这么叫它，它一直在沙沙作响。所以当他们穿过或越过——希望是越过——栏架时，你实际上会把这个声音渐强，如果你对此很在行的话，你可以稍微改变一下音量，听起来就像几匹马一起穿过障碍一样。这几乎是一个标准做法，我想这可能就是他们多年来一直使用的同一段录音。
Some horse racing events sound strange to me because they have this constant thundering sound and I can't tell if it's real or not. It's like in horse racing movies like I did see biscuit and all hat. I know you can hear the jockeys yelling and screaming at each other especially when they get tight on a turn. You hear the whips going. I recorded an Arabian horse. Arabians have a different gate than thoroughbreds. And I put four wireless mics or phones on each hoof. We wanted to control the speed of the horse, so we had the trainer run the horse in a circle with a rope. We wanted to control the movement because we have $12,000 in gear on the horse. He did kick one microphone off.
有些赛马赛事听起来很奇怪，因为它们有一种持续的雷鸣般的声音，我分不清那是真是假。就像在赛马电影里一样，比如我看过《奔腾年代》和《秘书处》。我知道你能听到骑师互相大喊大叫，尤其是当他们在转弯处挤在一起的时候。你能听到马鞭挥舞的声音。我录制了一匹阿拉伯马。阿拉伯马的步态与纯血马不同。我在每个蹄子上安装了四个无线麦克风。我们想要控制马的速度，所以我们让驯马师用绳子带着马转圈。我们想要控制动作，因为我们在马身上安装了价值12000美元的装备。他确实踢掉了一个麦克风。
If I was going to be in charge for the sound of a real event, I would want to do like the Kentucky Derby and use mycoras around the track and have some onboard mics and then have mics in the crowd and have mics on the gate. Of course racing fans, they get really crazy when they're cheering. Does people are yelling? Come on! Come on! They're screaming at the top of their lungs and yelling.
如果我要负责一场真实赛事的音效，我会想要像肯塔基赛马大会那样，在赛道周围使用麦克风，在赛车上安装一些车载麦克风，然后在人群中放置麦克风，在起跑闸门处放置麦克风。当然，赛马迷们在欢呼时会变得非常疯狂。人们在疯狂大喊：加油！加油！他们声嘶力竭地尖叫和呐喊。
Sixty! Darts is all about fun, so you know we like to have a bit of fun as well with the sand. So what we do is we use the real sand of the dart hitting the board to trigger some samples and we play around with kick drums, snare drums, dustbin's falling over and anything else we can find and it just adds a bit of fun really to what can you know get a bit repetitive. It's not real but it's enhances. That's something that I think most of us involved in sport, try and do, try and enhance the experience. We tread the middle road between what's real and what's unreal.
六十分！飞镖运动完全是为了乐趣，所以你知道的，我们也很喜欢在声音上加入一点乐趣。所以我们所做的是，利用飞镖击中靶盘的真实声音来触发一些采样，我们用大军鼓、小军鼓、倒下的垃圾桶以及我们能找到的任何其他东西来玩转声音，它确实为原本可能会变得有点重复的声音增添了一点乐趣。它不是真实的，但它增强了体验。这是我认为大多数参与体育运动的人都在努力做的事情，试图增强体验。我们在真实与不真实之间走了一条中间道路。
If you're sitting at the side of a basketball court from a TV point of view, the producers want to hear the ball as it goes through the net, the swishing of the net. And that is certainly something that you do not ever hear in the basketball arena. You only hear that on TV because it's exciting. Samuel L. Jackson, I came to teach boys and you became men. This is our time! Coach Carter. For Coach Carter, the supervising sound editor wanted me to get the sound of the basketball, but he wanted... there's a ping. I don't know if you've ever heard of basketball, but when you bounce it, it goes,
如果你从电视的角度坐在篮球场边，制作人想要听到篮球穿过篮网的声音，也就是篮网的摩擦声。这绝对是你在篮球场内永远听不到的声音。你只能在电视上听到，因为这样才刺激。塞缪尔·杰克逊，我来时你们还是男孩，而你们变成了男人。这是我们的高光时刻！《卡特教练》。对于《卡特教练》，声音总监要求我录制篮球的声音，但他想要……有一种清脆的撞击声。我不知道你有没有听过篮球的声音，当你拍击它时，它会发出，
bounce ping! And it kind of has this high airy ring. We did this great rim stuff, like rim slams, rim hits, net wishes, and then we're trying to capture the sound of this ping. And we were right under the net, and I'm like, no, that's not it. It just sounds like the big thud of a basketball and the reverb in the room.
砰！还带着一种高亢空灵的回音。我们做了很多棒极了的篮筐音效，比如扣篮、撞击篮筐、篮网摩擦声，然后我们试图捕捉这种清脆的声音。我们就站在篮网正下方，我说，不对，不是这个。听起来只像是篮球沉闷的撞击声和房间里的混响。
But then we went into the corner of the room, and I got elevated on the bleachers, and I had my microphone above the ball, and the guy slammed the ball on the ground, and then as the ball was coming up to my microphone, you hear the ping. I've always taken the approach to record the sound's documentary style like accurate and then I try to then find the next level up to go heightened reality. Sometimes you actually have to cheat a sound even bigger
但随后我们走到了房间的角落，我爬上了看台，把麦克风举在球上方，工作人员将球重重地砸在地上，然后当球弹向我的麦克风时，你听到了那种清脆的声响。我一直采取的方法是以纪录片风格录制准确的声音，然后我试着寻找下一个层次，打造强化现实感。有时你实际上必须把声音做得更加夸张
to make it cut through. The thing that Hollywood does differently is it sounds huge. The movies sound big, they sound rich. It's definitely more theatrical than real. Just think fast and furious or die hard. As we've been doing this over the years, sort of emulating broadcast and enhancing it, the broadcasters have been listening to what we've been doing and then using our techniques back in the actual broadcast.
才能让它脱颖而出。好莱坞的做法不同之处在于它听起来非常宏大。电影的声音听起来宏大、丰满。它绝对比现实更具戏剧性。想想《速度与激情》或《虎胆龙威》。随着我们多年来一直在做这件事，效仿广播并增强音效，广播公司一直在倾听我们的所作所为，然后将我们的技术应用回实际的广播中。
It's very interesting at ESPN, we told them, hey, we're trying to look at your broadcast model to try to sort of capture that classic broadcast thing, and then they told us, well, we've actually been playing your game, and we really love the fact that you guys, you know, push up the wooshes on the bats. So what they do now on broadcast is they actually zip those sounds up, meaning that, you know, when you listen to a baseball game now versus 10 years ago, you hear these big bat wooshes and arm throws and big fat catcher mitts, because they have mics located
非常有趣的是，在ESPN，我们告诉他们，嘿，我们正试图研究你们的广播模式，以试图捕捉那种经典的广播感，然后他们告诉我们，嗯，我们实际上一直在玩你们的游戏，我们非常喜欢你们这些人，你知道的，把球棒挥舞的声音调大。所以他们现在在广播中做的是，他们实际上把这些声音放大了，这意味着，你知道的，现在当你听一场棒球比赛与10年前相比时，你会听到这些巨大的挥棒声、手臂投掷声和巨大的厚实捕手手套声，因为他们放置了
very close to capture those sounds. Many years ago the audio that people would have been used to expecting from a football match would have been the ground noise and that was all. Whereas now they expect to hear every kick, every grunt, every whistle of the referee because that's what they get used to hearing on video games, on films that have been post-dubbed. So we're always trying to match that sort of sand.
非常近的麦克风来捕捉这些声音。多年前，人们习惯从足球比赛中听到的音频应该只是场地噪音，仅此而已。而现在，他们期望听到每一次踢球、每一次喘息、裁判的每一次哨声，因为那是他们在电子游戏、经过后期配音的电影中习惯听到声音。所以我们一直在努力匹配那种声音。
The challenge for me is to make sports on TV is engaging as film or video games. If we don't, we're going to lose out. But it's the challenge I welcome. I'm gearing up for London 2012 where the games will be presented in high-definition picture and certainly in surround sound. I'll be pushing to create the best, most involving, most detailed sound ever at the Olympics, and one thing that makes me very happy is I hear that the Vuvuzillas will be banned from the games. I leave you with one of my favorite sounds, the equestering jumping event. The Sound of Sport was presented by Dennis Baxter and produced by Peregrin Andrews. It was a fallen tree production originally produced for BBC Radio 4 in 2011.
对我的挑战是让电视上的体育节目像电影或电子游戏一样引人入胜。如果我们做不到，我们就会被淘汰。但我很欢迎这个挑战。我正在为2012年伦敦奥运会做准备，届时比赛将以高清画质呈现，当然还有环绕立体声。我将努力创造奥运会上最好、最身临其境、最细致的声音，有一件事让我非常高兴，那就是我听说呜呜祖拉将被禁止在奥运会上使用。我以我最喜欢的声音之一——马术障碍赛来结束本期节目。本期《体育之声》由丹尼斯·巴克斯特（Dennis Baxter）呈献，佩雷格林·安德鲁斯（Peregrin Andrews）制作。这是一档“陨树制作”（A Fallen Tree Production）节目，最初于2011年为BBC广播四台制作。
99% Invisible is Sam Greenspan, Katie Mingle, Avery Truffleman, and me, Roman Mars. The 99PI experience isn't just this episode you're hearing. We are also all on Twitter at Roman Mars, Sam listens, Katie Mingle and Truffleman. We're all still on Facebook, Tumblr, Instagram, Flickr, Spotify, SoundCloud. If you pick something out and search for 99% of visible, you're probably going to find us there. And you are always welcome to stop by our place at 99pi.org. Radio tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《99%隐形》的制作人员有萨姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）、凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）、艾弗里·特吕夫曼（Avery Truffleman），还有我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。99PI的体验不仅限于你听到的这一集。我们也都活跃在推特上，账号是Roman Mars、Sam listens、Katie Mingle和Truffleman。我们还在Facebook、Tumblr、Instagram、Flickr、Spotify和SoundCloud上。如果你挑出一些内容并搜索99%隐形，你很可能会在那里找到我们。而且随时欢迎你顺道访问我们的网站：99pi.org。广播塔皮奥。来自PRX。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。